So we can look at two
different policies or
models that make sense for
commercial environments.
We're going to start with orders
called the Clark-Wilson policy.
So Clark-Wilson policy says
that users should be able to
access certain programs or applications.
Objects are constrained and
certain objects can only be
accessed by certain programs.
So the way you think
about the policy is that
somebody says this user should have
access to this application, and
somebody says this application
should have access to these objects,
so that's what the user can then
gain access to those objects.
And only when they're
running those applications.
So if I want separation-of-duty, for
example, where the same person should be
able to do things that could
potentially lead to fraud, then we
can just say that user Alice cannot
execute both of those applications.
So, you can do one and
somebody else will need to
be able to run the other application and
that's how we separate the two duties
associated with the two
applications that we have here.
So, Clark Wilson essentially was
developed for commercial settings.
The second one is more about
the conflict of interest requirement,
how we address that.
And the name of the policy is
called Chinese Wall Policy,
and we'll see why this is
an appropriate name for it.
So the deals, as we said,
with conflict of interest and
what you can access or cannot access
depends on what you have seen so far.
So what you've seen so far,
if it has no conflict with the next
thing you're asking for then it's okay.
If not, then we're going to deny access.
So how do we decide when
do you have a conflict or
the absence of that
conflict of interest?
To explain this conflict of interest and
the Chinese Wall Policy a little bit
more, let's say we have
a document on a system.
Now some documents
are financial documents
that pretend to different banks.
So Chase, Wells Fargo,
Bank of America, whatever it is.
So this grouping here, these are all the
documents that are for Bank of America.
These are all the documents for
Wells Fargo and so on.
Okay, similarly we have other
documents that pertain to, let's say,
oil companies.
So some documents are Exxon,
others Shell, Chevron, and so on.
The reason we have this outer box
around all the bank documents or
oil company documents is that
this is a conflict class.
Chase has a conflict with Wells Fargo
because they're in the same
kind of business so
they compete with each other.
So the conflict class is, you know,
these documents form the conflict.
Similarly, Exxon would have
a conflict with Shell and Chevron.
So these documents are in
this other conflict class.
Okay.
So Chinese Wall Policy
basically says a user can access
any object as long as he or she
has not accessed an object from another
company In the same conflict class.
So let's say user Alice accesses Exxon,
okay, a document pertaining to Exxon.
She can because so
far she has accessed nothing, so
there's no conflict that we can see.
As soon as she accesses a document
from this class, from Exxon.
She cannot access anything in these
other classes that are in the same
conflict class.
So she can't access something
that belongs to Shell or Chevron.
Can she then go and access
a document that pertains to Chase?
Yes, that's in a different
conflict class.
There's no conflict between Chase and
Exxon.
Alice can access this and this.
But as soon as she does Chase
she can't access Wells Fargo, so
you can basically access
any oil company and
any bank but not two oil companies and
not two banks at the same time.
So we're basically creating these
walls around sets of documents, okay.
That a conflict exists across those and
that's why it's called
a Chinese Wall Policy.